welcome to this video round two of the
Norway 2013 super tournament um I
actually didn't have the time to check
them if it has got some fancy name or it
is really just the Norway 2013 but game
let them start with the games I'll start
with them and to pull off against their
job of and this is actually not the most
exciting game I'll just go through it
rather briefly because we've got them
much more interesting stuff on happening
in this round yeah the raw Sony mode I'm
very popular choice to avoid the open
decision and we get a line that has been
discussed in the London candidates
exactly this was played between cards
and enter and Gafford and here in this
position on Galvan actually played
Bishop d7 and see for this was some what
happened in the game the job off came up
with the new idea 95 and at least i
think its new i don't have any game with
it in my database maybe it has been
played only very recently but it also
could be a really new idea um I'm not
sure that I really understand the move
on to me it seems rather logical to
exchange it on default like em galfond
did later in the game and where's the
snide actually going to ok but as as
mentioned i didn't want to spend too
much time of this so
this is a very direct idea but the part
of b6 is weekend and he wants to use
this immediately quite a quite
interesting way to play now black must
be I care across as if you exchange here
then the Snyder some it's really a
problem and um like it's really on the
defensive it's Nazis even to get rid of
this not so maybe ideas like this and
now this this black should avoid and Raj
overplayed Queenie five getting the
Queen to an active square and actually
now attacking the knight on e4 yeah
tactical response attacking the Queen
and 94 yeah I know 94 it looks a bit
strange to walk into South pin where
this was for jobs idea and after this
there's still this night under tech so
white doesn't have the time to to pin it
with f3 or something he needs to to move
the knight on e4 first and now like it's
got this this move which simplifies the
position yet yep I think it's clear that
white only has some rather small
advantage but it's it's still something
we see that in the game it always looks
like em white it has got a slight
something but it's not much it judgments
falls now like it's got this Paul
weakness but this is this is all other
than that he's got no problems and we
see that in the game it was some
it was drawn after not much more play
yeah get some some more exchanges and
adhered it was drawn actually you could
look at the the last 20 moves or so here
this this kind of stuff this is not a
completely pointless this this phase of
the game but then I don't want to make a
three hour video I mean the other games
to really have have more more
interesting things to to watch okay now
switch to them on paper main event of
the day carlton against ireland and sort
of a warm-up for the world championship
match and certainly carlton wants to
press a bit with white we got the moscow
variation yeah the Bishop b5 check I'm
cows and avoids the main lines um this
is very common to see and play em some
sideline ideas beaten none anand with
Bishop b5 check before so why not 97 now
this is a slight surprise maybe I'll not
have played this move before but with
the really bad results and he usually
plays Bishop d7 if he's content with the
draw which she certainly is in this game
um but he lost with this also against
garden last year okay 97 d for this is
the way to go after 97 white them
immediately gets the Queen out and this
is actually a low place screen because
the natural attack with 96 is not
possible anymore what black does gain
though is the bishop path that makes no
sense for y2 to retreat the bishop
so this is exchange and now Wyatt set up
the typical maroc see bind getting a
space advantage and hoping to to press
in the in the middle game so some it
seemed very often in Carlin's games to
that he likes to to get to this
structure even if it is under sometimes
um less favorable circumstances even
then he goes for that I mean this is not
the greatest setup ever probably for
white but it's still a little something
'if i've knowed queen d 3 and now on a
plate b5 this is a surprise it's a very
rare mood he be formed in this position
played to move h6 against them but yeah
Russian Dutch Grand Master negative
Yakov he played this last year in the
Bundesliga the german first league when
he was trying to warm up a bit of the
match against gelfand and he actually
lost against the TV Yakov a very drastic
loss um probably one of the most painful
losses that he that he suffered because
he really didn't even have a threat the
whole game it was just a terrible
destruction that that TV a coffin did in
this game okay but this time he's got
something else prepared be five
immediately try to open up the position
on the queenside and we see that this is
successful I mean like opened up the
queenside and very quickly managed to
exchange those two pawns which um should
be something that helps black but it's
not so easy as we will see right now
goes for a very good maneuver night e 1
c 2 e 3 at e3 is the ideal square for
the night we'll see why let's put it
down this is simply the best square for
this piece it supports 95 now two nights
can go there it goes to f5 it's a
possibility and also there's night c4 so
just a very good position of the night
and we see that black now needs to be
careful to to keep the balance to not
get hit by by night d 59 seaforth looks
like that that's it was very difficult
to play for white but 95 is a nonworking
that black tries to exchange Queens and
um here it actually happened maybe I'm
and um miscalculated something here he
took with the rook and I think maybe in
originally and he had he had intended to
take with this but here that's a nice
idea what can't go 95 if the bishop
moves play before attending b5 of course
black cannot take after Knight takes
it's a funny fork of the torques maybe
he didn't really appreciate that idea so
he was forced to take with this rocker
and this is not what he wanted certainly
getting away from the sea file and this
is what the cars doesn't know how he
uses his piece activity and get some a
couple of moves later look on the
seafoam
and i only saw this position known when
i was i think i was was riding on a
train to him to my um to my own to the
place where my claw / club is playing
and i only saw this position on the
mobile phone i thought okay well this is
almost in the back for cards it looks
very very tricky to to defend for black
white has got excellent nights very good
structure a five oops no a five is a
weakness d6 as a weakness so i thought
this should be should be really
excellent for white let's see what
happens you should be five yeah and
actually in this position we are
counting played roots III and here the
computer has got the simple right away
super suggestion of just taking and
plain idea and it gives white a
substantial really really substantial on
advantage this is probably true d 6 is
very hard to defend and there's also the
apron so yeah let's for example if like
defense passively with Bishop e7 there's
just this move and no way now to cover
the a pawn why it is just winning the
spawn there can you can play here but
one can just can just take it or take
first here maybe this is more precise
and why this excellent is just got da
phone and that's the weaknesses in bed
pieces so it's virtually winning for
what in this case so um after this I'm
really not sure how black should defend
here you can try to do to go for
activity like like this year but
after this the night on these 7 has to
move and then I can can just take here
this Bishop is also really dominating
this night it cannot go to a natural
square like c5 and after this what is
really no yes even H for you so it
cannot even go to f6 ya need to go here
this gets worse and worse yeah I can
take here I can prepare this how to how
to to keep any way that you five pawns
also so this weakness yeah this looks
very bad maybe rook takes his 697 was
the way to go but then it may be needs a
little bit more analysis after Luke's
III however um honored could exchange
some pieces and now sets up a very
passive but resilient defense the night
on b7 is very rarely a good piece and
here it is nothing ya know nothing
activist coming from this piece but it
does a very important job in covering
the weaknesses and it's maybe nice
looking for white but not really winning
when cars will try to try it for a while
but didn't really make any any progress
yeah if you look at this it still looks
good for white of you the passive night
against an active night their weaknesses
and there's the potential past porn but
like has got counterplay it's not so
obvious but he's got something just have
a look h5
auntie delays the submit with f5 but at
the end here it comes d 5 + f5 so what
wasn't able to to keep this blockade
maybe I'm he needs to find something
better here but it's it's not so easy
also this rook now I did the occupies a
half open file and black maybe even can
play here and f5 and it's it's not easy
at all to make any any real progress in
the game it really fizzled out 22 pretty
much nothing after d5 John I dent game
but okay they are simply not annoyed
enough material on the board and here
yeah draw I'm not even agreed to draw on
this is a technical drop of course um I
mean this is something you can claim
that the arbiter okay so I'm yeah draw
form for cards and only a draw after the
the way the game proceeded he probably
was slightly disappointed I didn't
manage to to yet look at some player
statements but I think he probably was
disappointed because it looked like
white had an excellent position maybe it
really was some here that you should
have taken on c6 but um it's it's
possible the way it was played it was
still better for white and this is very
often an essential problem in chess in
good positions and bad positions you
know you know you're better or you know
you're worse and you know that you have
more than one possible moves available
that probably doesn't change the
evaluation
too much so you keep your advantage or
you you keep being worse but it's very
hard to choose between similar-looking
our similar strong-looking moves and
actually increase the advantage not just
keep it and maybe he choose the wrong
way to to continue to to play were
through this edge and let it fizzle out
okay at some softly um a matter of a
deeper analysis if the game had some
improvements for white but at least the
quick overview that the data tried um
didn't show up anything really only this
group texts six possibility okay so
let's now move on to the other games and
let's start with hammer hammer against
the Sega coyoacán and this hammer name
is always fun wouldn't it be fun if he
would I don't know I don't want to do
any kind of rumors he or something
wouldn't it be fun if he would marry a
Irina Krush the the US top female player
double name crush hammer or a hammer
crush or something would be fun alright
so let's go to the game they play the
Queen's Indian defense here this is some
kayak ends main opening against you for
the news oh and the Queen Simeon and um
it's a fairly fairly normal line this
Bishop before check is a very common
theme and queen pawns openings to to
lure this Bishop on d to where doesn't
really want to be and then returned to
his heaven yeah if all this is the most
ambitious way provides two to play this
if um just castle and play it down more
conservatively than after d5 it's not so
easy to even be able to play before so
he goes um I had with this immediately
d5 and now he takes on d5 p.m. and white
can also try if I've but here black even
can go to before this is some very nice
possibility and in fact white has some
problems with this pressure on c4 so if
I was not the way to go he exchanged and
played Knight e5 now here using the pin
on the long diagonal yeah in fact them I
think they played very standard normal
looking moves I didn't like some
maneuvers that white was playing but it
still was okay yeah note that if like
here like takes there's a possibility of
going before and now the night hanks and
this Bishop is cut off so cannot take on
a three returned Creed III am trying to
get rid of the snide f6 kicks the night
back Andrew p8 so there wasn't much
happening really now he exchanged and
played f3 adds difficult to to live with
this neither of the time so try to expel
it 926
yeah this position now he played the
move b5 and this is really a mistake but
it's not so easy to see and probably he
made a calculation error out the white
player here yeah maybe treat this as a
small exercise sighs what new phone
should like play now I'll be silent a
couple of seconds of you want to pause
it how black has the very strong move
Knight c2e 5pm and this is probably what
hama missed on somehow miss miss judge
um now it gets really tricky for for
white what's the problem he took it and
this is some probably relatively best
way to go about it move like wing b3 is
answered by night C form and this is
also not great something like this it's
simply better for black you're very
offside night and all this is not
exactly harmonious while black has got
ideas to block with Bishop d5 getting
the bishop back it's um it's not nice to
play this is white especially long-term
your king is weak with this pawn moves
he took it we captured and now the point
is revealed this bishop doesn't have a
square and black am really care even
threatens to to catch on and fall so you
cannot play a slow move like let's let's
just putting nothing move on the board
it doesn't make much sense I know but
after taking yeah this is just the wreck
don't want to have this position
everything's weekend so he took it
Knight takes Queen d4 and queen have six
and now we see that white really is in
deep trouble he's got lots of weaknesses
Black's got the bishop pal and whites
pieces are I really news the night on
III and what is the light doing on a for
a minute at least to prevent some Bishop
c5 but it's not a great piece look
Kingdom in the corner that was the night
air three thread with check and winning
the Queen so step down on this and now I
too am 27 this is a good good human move
the computer actually gives a queen F
sadness even stronger if you let it
calculate for a while the ideas night to
see form at opening up the position
known as much as possible this is maybe
even better than what what the kayaking
plate but this is a very human move he
recognizes that the queen is sub
locating piece and if you get rid of it
your poem on the deform it's really a
good pants porn it's difficult for white
to play anyway p retreated the capture i
think is really terrible what i do now
is the noise need to probably can't drop
it back somewhere then maybe rook c8 or
something it's it's really tough for
whites to defend this very clear
advantage for black so it went TM and
now hey i can play tonight c5 around
here i'm black hat a multitude of good
possibilities this is so of course good
and should be better for black but it's
not so sure that it's really the best
generation but okay I can always kept
some advantage okay he gave up the porn
but his his place is just as strong look
at this rookie three Andrew create just
doubling here on the file attending
rookie to look a three Bishop and three
so it's a it's a really really nice
attack that black got here would be one
exchange stuff and now he decided to get
the porn bag and break through to the
king rook takes Bishop takes and this is
actually not the most precise move it
seems that rook takes a threesome is
somewhat stronger still intending to
play this move with slight problem with
this is now after here it is difficult
now for black to avoid the trade of the
bishops and this Jesus White's a defense
of it but it's still not not at all easy
in fact in this position um now ha ma
move 40 he didn't have much time I mean
you cannot trust the clock say one
hundred percent but it's clear that he
was down on time played the 96 which is
in fact as it turns out a serious
mistake um probably he needed to play a
roof like you one maybe this I don't
know or queen d7 that's a possibility um
the problem is why this is so
problematic is that black has got this
move a five and this is really strong
it's um it's a bit of them it's much
stronger than you then you might think
at first and what is this form of doing
you're on a seven it was a slight
weakness attacked by the night and now
there's no weakness anymore
this night is now on c6 but what it is
doing its not threatening anything or
taking anything in the near future the
problem is that those pawns here are
potentially much weaker the bishop on c5
covers v6 very nicely so this is some
sort of a hewlett turn a black unit
those three of three pieces covering
each other it's very nicely coordinated
and those pawns are are still weak and
we see that that really quickly gets
important coyoacán exchanged and now
look to um II for ya here maybe yum was
one problem I mean one from this the
wrong phrase now it gets gets much more
problematic he played now look at five
it seems that whoopsie one was somewhat
better the ideas that rook takes a for
as a blunder really a mistake due to the
capture and now the palm promotes it
seems that this is in fact about air not
it's not about equal it seems to be a
draw I analyze this a bit so on like
it's very unlucky with the stroke he
needs to lose a move
yeah those parts they look dangerous but
it's um it's just the drawn it's not
easy to calculate a noun and an over the
ballgame this pulse can be very scary
but it is probably really just to draw
for example a 496 see form yeah this is
maybe even risky the night on before and
then look at the King approaches let
let's keep it simple this is actually a
real draw and now the King moves them in
this direction and if white goes all the
way to be two then the black king goes
to the Kings side end wins the pawns
this was a very important technical
trick and of course Hamas saw that the
differences after here if black plays
strengthening like this attacking the
rook it continues and it's not so clear
that white has made any a great head
black has made any great progress he can
certainly play on and we'll play on
simply also because the Snyder's
basically dominated now it doesn't have
a square the the problem in the game was
after you gave 5 which is doing a
similar thing if black takes now we have
the sacrifice again the problem is that
doesn't really help in the long run as
like now just want to share with the
king and can now take the pawn the
progress da porn is simply the much the
much stronger porn then then the h2porn
or one of those two points and black is
some is winning in this position there's
no way to defend it this is just a
pretty useless piece now
yeah and now resigns the a porn is just
promoting there's no way to to stop it
yeah a good game by kayaking at UM he
always had at least an equal position
and then after Hama allowed this in the
shot he kept an advantage most of the
time probably hear of something else
like like work t1 offered better
defensive chances in the ensuing endgame
it's very difficult to hold I believe if
possible at all so when ya the second
blossom of hammer but kayaking won his
second game so his own on two out of two
very nice start for them yes still young
russian his feels like he's around
forever and he's 23 years old ok so I'm
next game but the next game yeah let's
go one with one how against swidler yes
we love sticking to his guns let's play
grew felt and wong hau place f3 the some
really got into fashion after the the
world championship match where are not
played this moves a couple of times
they're diaz to to threaten in a way we
form so black needs to react now if he
wants to stay within the goon fraud
schemes he needs to play d5 however he's
got a ton of interesting alternatives
swidler himself has played 96 in the
past some interesting tricky move all
this even of course there's always a
transposition to the king's indian you
can just allow this and it's king's
indian
and that's also the funny movie 6 which
can be investigated so if you play this
as black going for the blue thought and
I'm f3 as a move that annoys you there
are quite a number of I'm not so well
tested ways to go like this e 6 it was
very fresh or even 96 okay what's really
a place d5 it sits in all it's an okay
move no no problem so got this position
and this also shows one idea of this f3
set up with the white playing efore in a
position where there is no knight on c3
you make sure that you get the broad
center here and you don't have any
pieces exchange which in general should
favor the site with the with more space
and this is yeah right of course but
okay those general considerations are
very difficult to to live by in a very
concrete position we see that it gets
very concrete through the place queen d
6 which is somehow unpopular in this
position it seems it seems a bit weird
to me but this is some may be also
matter of matter of chess taste might be
five and drops back at four young queen
e6 all very tactical now I'm first
glance you think okay d5 and winning
things but in fact this is not winning
for why that's losing this some
it's very very bad for white what this
is supposed to do if you block it like
this with with the check and there's all
kinds of things hanging now so let's
let's say here take d3 after this
there's still this hanging so blackest
is just winning in this position d 5 is
really a blunder and down rather well
known he had dropped back if you look at
the clock times swidler has spent a bit
of time but not much and run how was I
was on more time than that it was that
it started with though he blitzed out on
his booth Nancy phone yeah blacks place
lots of times place with the same piece
all the time and losing time in the
process look at this this caused some
time but okay you you netted yourself
the the bishop so this is this is at
least something yeah so what's villa is
trying to do with them moves like this
is to provoke widen creating weaknesses
and he's intending to attack those
weaknesses later in the game it didn't
really work out well let's see what
happens okay white covers the A to point
it was attacked to now move d 8 yeah
this is
of course helping to increase the
pressure on default why develops and
right here is the position where black
is is running out of moves with this
pieces the thing is so in all those
hyper-modern openings like the groom
felt and yeah you can continue this
applies also to Latins depends on your
hands defense I try with the
pronunciation very often when you say or
whether the books say oh ok you control
the center or I take the center with
pieces and not with points this is often
only temporarily true at one point you
need to put something in the center and
somehow it feels to me that black is in
a position here where it is difficult to
put something in the center how am I
going to do that I mean c5 is not
possible it looks at least like you
cannot place you five um yeah Indy
fibers it's very very ugly for black
it's just a good Center and I have a
look at this just for example I mean now
while I'm of course respect those hyper
modern ideas this is certainly just
great for white those two pawns why just
dominates in the center and the sir this
must be terrible for black you cannot go
see five and how do you continue if
you're not going to attack the center
with the pilot some time I mean yeah
maybe you can delay all this even longer
the computer for instance just suggested
to play something like this and may
continue with c6 even a 3 and even c6
because white cannot easily take it in
fact maybe this kind of position as
something black and play it wouldn't
appeal to me much to fit a play this is
black but it's not immediately busted
however in this position nurse villa he
had just panicked probably because he
couldn't make c5 work which he intended
I suspect he played the move b5 and it
was really played rather quickly I know
maybe it was also some kind of lapsim in
reproducing some preparation the only
thing that I know is that rock how
played a three-night drop back he took
the porn and black absolutely does not
have enough compensation I mean of
course we didn't blunder this year was
aware that he needs some counter play
again the center and here it's not so
much central how to play what potential
play on the B file but if you look at at
this couple of moves um it's it's clear
that black does not have enough 95 was a
good move intending moves like this or
maybe 96 black doesn't have a choice he
needs to take it and I mean at least
after this it's clear that white is much
better any play on the beep beep horn on
the King can easily diffuse by defending
the second-ranked this is just a bad
piece and the rest is some
yeah a matter of technique one of those
phrases you you simply must hate but it
is it is somewhat true white is got
nicks trapani dominates in the center
and there's no concrete play for black
ok continue a bit here the technical
sequence at the end the lighter comes to
this excellent c 6 square and down c put
some more moves on the board yeah he
grabbed the pawn it was probably good
but a decision you need to be careful
with us the night has no squares and
locate some potential threat but it was
all nicely calculated by about how f 50
and what about this there's the strong
movie 6 now attacking the bishop and
attacking on f7 so what is some like
supposed to do now after takes white
goes to c6 and just enjoys an extra porn
and the dominating night at the NDA porn
will decide the game here this is why he
probably played f5 to later attack the
night but Dwight can evacuate this piece
buying a sacrificing porn and okay he
was two pawns up now is only one part up
but then it's it's simply an excellent
position some transformations going on I
only want to show subset of this is why
I'm going ahead rather quickly
check check okay exactly until this
point this is what one how had in mind
from this position here on the best way
to set up White's pieces together look
on the fourth rank which covers the porn
on edge for its champion group here it
covers the porn so you don't need to
worry about that the rook maybe can
switch over to the queenside it covers
checks on g4 and white can just advance
the airport it's everything is nicely
protected and term okay he fought on for
a while but it did really help at the
end is the a pawn note how everything is
defended this is the sign of a good
piece coordination they've got no loose
pieces everything's defending each other
okay yeah until he resigns the the
simple point being after I rookie move
like here it's even this end very
difficult to defend this in fact even
impossible so wyd wins yet another pawn
and this is an additional problem so I'm
kind of an opening disaster he must feel
I'm not sure maybe confused something in
his preparation but this v5 is certainly
um a move that probably no one will be
repeat in a serious game at least
alright so we only got one game left and
this is Aronian against Anakin 10 people
might have
might start yawn now because the
exchange slav but okay I've played this
opening many times and tournament chess
and it has got some some nice aspects
you rarely lose the game you can
sometimes press a bit and win and one
point about this is also that the
regular lines and the sloths are not
exactly great for white as well so it's
not like em okay em I'm lazy I played
the exchange because I don't want to
learn all those great lines that white
can go for there are simply not not any
brilliant lines that white can play
together a very safe advantage or
something I think the exchange Slav is
is the line that it's useful to have in
your opening repertoire if you play
default as imagine it is safe and you
can still win games of black is not
careful and even if he is careful there
there are some some things to play for
yeah note that aronian played the tricky
move over here he kept the night on g1
and this is some factor helpful to try
to create something here what is black
so close are supposed to play now the
easiest to go is Bishop to f5 and this
is also probably the main continuation
and it can also transpose to to the
absolute main line however here white
has some additional options you can go
queen bee three for instance or also
Roxy one he doesn't need to play Knight
f3 necessarily and what else is some let
going to pluck you don't want to play
Bishop f5 um yeah there's this a six
ideas which is usually answered with
this and in fact in the game we will get
this position
bye bye transposition and that's also
the move Bishop g4 and this is what my
camera plate funny enough Bishop g4 it's
not a bad move i played this myself a
couple of times as black because some
time ago and i played the Slav regularly
and this was my choice it's black
against this queen bee three attacking
me seven there's also f3 with the idea
to push g4 quickly leads to interesting
play it's not exactly draw okay South
Bishop g4 queen bee three Knight a5 good
move but some very concrete sequence now
why does Sir threatening to win a poem
that the bishop takes a disciplined
black only has got 1,000,000 move in 96
if you play a move like this and you are
sort of not paying attention then you
can easily get to get into trouble here
93 95 I move like night b5 it's not
leading to much black and black and
cover it this is just a bit too slow
yeah yeah there are there certain ideas
for white and the easiest move however
son is night to to c6 yeah now black and
some need a way threatening to play a 6
so if you go here a 6 then y term it's
basically you don't want to avoid what
you want to avoid those kind of moves
widest probably am taking now and you
really don't want to give up the bishops
so a six is the real threat so white
just drop the Queen back a six we should
be three we should be fine now we after
some curious move water tricks we
transpose to the line starting with
asics which I just a short before 92
yeah this is important why it doesn't
want to go Knight f3 because um let's
just put it on the board something like
this is it's really two equal impossible
to to get anything here 92 is a bit a
bit tougher trying to keep this ideas on
the position yeah we should be seven
there also is always Bishop d6 which is
not bad for black what this was all very
normal right tending to go here yeah
this position it is difficult to
tolerate this night so when a camera
captured it and now what what happens in
the next couple of moves is really I
think I'm very very good and interesting
play by Union and the the almost
automatic moves let's say in in a quick
play game in a blitz game or something
at least if I think what I would would i
play this is rook c5 keeping the
structure you've got two bishops and so
on but after Bishop g6 them it's not not
much going on actually those pieces will
be exchanged and it's questionable how
wide is making any progress however he
played details which probably wouldn't
have crossed my mind because it gives
black those central pawns but uronian
very nicely um assess that he's got
chances in this position maybe also part
the preparation is possibly blends
playing very quickly but have a look at
this Bishop g5 and um and h6 it's
difficult to to keep this pin I mean
what is black so supposed to play maybe
he could have played this one but ok
went h6 maybe also under estimating what
what's happening now took and 93 this is
a slight problem peace what is black
supposed to do now if you go Bishop g6
can just take it and take care and black
it's basically busted it's an extra porn
and an overwhelming position so what to
do with the bishop was all very concrete
and Rihanna camera had to cover it with
the Queen and now I'm very interesting
with Queen d2 what is this move doing
threatens f4 and this is very very
strong white couldn't play up f1 of
course immediately because the queen is
hanging so this is this make sense but
the problem is f40 has strong move if
black plays and nothing reply let's say
here then f4 is at this this is just
just terrible for like this is such a
liability this piece and why it has the
multitude of options can even can even
go here if you want so I'm very nice for
wide so Nakamura played the the normal
move who played to a default attacking
here and activating the center and here
the hoolian plate clean one is really
honey career d2 and queen you are and
what is happening now
they're from black let's start with the
simple stuff but I cannot take here yes
this is hanging and it still is a for
threat so display supposed to play in
the game you played the capture and this
turns out to be to be a really difficult
like it's probably a very serious
mistake um bishop g6 is the most that
the computer recommends but I'm to be
perfectly honest I don't understand the
computer assessment it says that or it
evaluates a computer doesn't speak this
kind of position only am slightly better
for white but I think black is in big
trouble here with got this terrible h7
Bishop and no big idea to to activate it
this is certainly certainly am better
for white and also not not only slightly
better and this this means that black is
in trouble what what are you going to
play now f4 is serious well he took only
three and 94 now leads to a very nice
position wins the tempo and off to d6 so
I think it's just a great concept he
maneuvered the night 2 g-3 z 46 and it
was really necessary to get to combine
it all with this F for ideas and now
right got the pawn back and just justice
an excellent champion he's got fantastic
night on d6 which really hinders blacks
hope the whole game he's got the
potential past porn on the air on the on
the queenside with three against two the
bishop is still off site
so brilliant position and widest it's
very very very good young probably it is
close to the to the size of edge already
yeah went Bishop g6 it's very difficult
to manage without the smooth at least in
this configuration there 5m squares
covered but it's still of course very
very good for wide yeah Queen trade and
he sees good all the time in the world
instead of this there was also the more
straightforward move before but it
doesn't really matter much what I'm just
needs to make sure that black doesn't
break out in some way he's got a very
emo boil corn structure everything's
blocked him and as long as white um
matches to keep black on the last couple
of ranks so we cannot advance any of his
pawns then with some do preparation you
will advance on the queenside and this
is just what happened a five stop this
for a while but then there's no way to
defend now we five hangs here by the
might and there's also this idea which
cuts off the rook and this is in fact
what happened in the game the rock was
cut off he didn't even bother taking
here or something okay a phone and yeah
the pawn is one away for
yeah note again I am mentioned this time
and time again that all pieces are
covering each other there's no loose
piece in this position everything's
nicely covered this is covered by the
rook and so on so white position is some
it's nicely working together all pieces
and have some useful role and okay now
cameras trying to muddy the waters a bit
but that's not really helping this is
three against one on the queenside this
is just a very strong and now they're
marching note that the rook is really
cut off yeah those has powers are strong
yeah I don't know like and where I still
continues to play even with a rope down
I'm not so sure what the point of this
might be but okay couple of moves later
yes I don't know why this was still
plate don't know and here he resigned to
being a rope down which is true for
about ten moves now but he didn't resign
before that so I think a very nice game
by aronia and this concept with the
Queen d2 we are preparing this f4 idea
and then after let's do it this way
preparing this a 4 idea and playing with
this idea against this Bishop with the
consequence that with D for the e4
square was open for the levels really
really a great concept and I think this
really am
and that to the almost the decisive edge
form for white the question is what did
black do wrong here maybe around him he
had some more precise way to play maybe
if I was even a bit premature you can of
course all the time play em in a
position like this drawback can always
play this kind of movers which at least
would ensure that this Bishop is traded
in the game it was a liability a huge
liability maybe a me five was really a
bit too quick on Bishop g6 here it's not
great maybe you can improve on h6e em
but i'm not i'm not so sure maybe if I
this really am a bit of a bit of a
premature move and this is this is
better yeah I wonder if this is
something for white or just just equal
probably it's just equal it's not not so
much that white can do here next let's
got this counter play ideas but it's not
um gay is not confronted with this
problems of the the bishop being offside
on age five all right so this was a
coverage of the second round we had free
the size of games and also interesting
drawing cards and not many Magnus had
some chances to to win this but it
wasn't wasn't easy at all and there are
three decisive games aronian one long
how one and kayaking with black young
who knows and they lead with two wins
yeah hope you enjoyed the video I'm
continue to carry this tournament of
course can only be the case that devan's
once in a while in the upcoming rounds
that I'm not doing it instantly after
the round because it tends to get really
late here alright thanks for watching